he's this fascist piece of [ __ ]
okay oh speaking of a racist
let's go to uh candace owens
and um uh her tweety tweets here
the uh
look at the uh
this is a screenshot obviously
let's see shane's something about
australia no that's not the one i want
that's not the one i want
that's that's not what i want stop
[ __ ] thing
uh
it's it's not working like i want it to
work i try to zoom in so you guys can
see it and
you know all that kind of good stuff but
sometimes the controls just don't work
the way i want them to but apparently uh
this morning oh here mayo will give us
an update here i always like mayo
good morning mayo
good morning to everyone except candice
owens who wants to declare war against
australia
she's so damn stupid yes she [ __ ] is
she is a [ __ ] bonehead
[ __ ] bonehead
you made the shitless roundup male
shitless roundup made
so uh let's see
[Music]
uh grant stern has got a good one here
can we vote can we vote to send candace
owens to australia is that a thing is
that a thing we can vote for i mean
maybe we can
i don't know maybe we can do that
thanks for your tweet grant
thanks for the tweet grant
so what's uh so i think because you know
we've got a lot of resistors here on
twitter right
so maybe
maybe just maybe like like a vendor
resistor here he's got a he's got a
tweet about candace owens maybe what we
do
is
since the
the [ __ ] list is a subsect
of the resist
maybe instead of resistor
we call the subsets of resistors who
watch the [ __ ] list
and who make the [ __ ] list we call them
[ __ ] listers
shitlisters you made the [ __ ] list
so maya's mayo today is a shitlister
grant stern is a shitlister
avenger resistor
is a shitlister candace owens is on
some donald trump jr and mike lindell
type crack
absolutely off her [ __ ] rocker
apparently she thinks uh
i guess let's do this i think it works
better when we yeah i think that works
better um
apparently she thinks that um australia
needs to be invaded or some [ __ ] because
i don't know they
they
somehow this [ __ ] australia thing has
seeped its way into american culture
where australia is being taken over or
some [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ] they got
this idea that australia is some kind of
like
like nazi germany over there or
something and it's it's not uh you
remember
uh uh
last week they had to put out a [ __ ]
statement in australia like no no
nope ted cruz yeah well here it is here
it is
um jewish gender resistor says cairness
owens and ted cruz are calling for the
u.s to invade
uh the texas of the pacific australia
to free the oppressed people from covet
tyranny
australia makes texas look worse than
they already do these two morons need to
shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up
trump would look into it though yeah if
he was president he definitely would
because here's ted cruz's uh tweet
i love the ics their history is
rugged independence it's legendary i've
always said australia is the texas of
the pacific
the covetery of their current government
is disgraceful and sad he really he
really does sound like donald trump like
if you read this in donald trump's voice
does it sound like donald trump you
notice these [ __ ] are doing
this you see how they're they're
adopting his language
they're adopted this is ted cruz was a
solicitor general
right this guy went before the supreme
court and this is the tweet he's writing
about this
read this in donald trump's was i'm not
a very good donald trump impersonator
but
individual liberty matters i stand with
the people of australia what's funny
about this is uh australia put out a
statement they're like no you're
completely [ __ ] wrong you're
completely [ __ ] wrong there's no
tyranny uh if you mean if you mean no
deaths from covid
and uh
we we reduced the death because we we
took mitigation tactics seriously to
make sure disease didn't spread and kill
our citizens
then yeah tyranny you [ __ ] idiot what
are you talking about we just protected
and kept our [ __ ] country safe yeah
that's that's what we did when we had a
war against a [ __ ] pandemic
tyranny get the [ __ ] out of here so
australia has some of the best [ __ ]
numbers in the world when it comes to
covid and the reason why is they took
their mitigation tactics seriously we
didn't
we didn't in this country
large swaths of our country still are
not taking mitigation tactics seriously
they're [ __ ] they're going on the
ivermectin facebook groups and believing
a bunch of disinformation when they
could just run on down to the [ __ ]
pharmacy their local pharmacy and get
the vaccine the best mitigation tactic
that's out there
aside from mass and social distancing
and these people you know they complain
about the pandemic they want to end the
pandemic right right that's the thing oh
yeah we want to end the pandemic
but they don't want to do the things to
do that they don't want to [ __ ] bone
heads
thank you jewish
resistor
appreciate that
mr race bannon says if a republican
tells you they have a black friend it's
candace owens
okay well i can't
i can't resist that one
that one's gonna end up on here
let's give it to some credit here thank
you very much for your tweet
mr mr race bannon
[ __ ] candice owens [ __ ] candace owens
[ __ ] her
she's a dumb [ __ ] what a dumb [ __ ]
oh i thought that was nazi it's not nazi
trending it's mozzie not nazi